we are now ready to learn how to search
for longest passes not only in simple
Manhattan like grades but in arbitrary
alignment drops here's an example of a
graph and in this case there is only one
way to move to these three nodes from
the source and there is also only one
way to move to this node from the source
but when we move to this node shown by
the question mark there are actually
four different ways to move to this node
which one should we choose in this one
in this case they actually have four
choices and as before we choose the
variant which provides the longest path
in this case this path is the optimal
one and we know that the optimal path
from 0 to the show known has blanston
the continue doing this and in the end
we will construct this graph with this
every node marked by the length of the
longest path and we will learn that the
length of the longest path from the
source to the sank is 29 and as before
we of course preserved the backtracking
pointers and that's why we will know how
to move back in this graph and find the
optimal path itself as a result for we
now know how to construct recurrency for
the dynamic programming in alignment
graph if we define s IJ as the length of
a longest path from 0 0 to I J then in
the alignment graph where we have
diagonal edges corresponding to the
alignment gauge we have three choices
you can either compute s IJ s s I minus
1 J plus weight of the vertical edge
into node I J or s I minus 1 J plus
rate of horizontal edge into IJ or s s
minus 1 J minus 1 plus weight of the
diagonal edge into I J and as a result
our recurrency for the longest common
subsequence problem becomes particularly
simple because the weight of all edges
in the longest subsequence problem is 0
except for the red edges that correspond
to merchants lettuce and sorry for the
currency is simply s I minus 1 J plus 0
or s IJ minus 1 plus 0 we can drop 0 of
course from this equation
o s I minus 1 J minus 1 plus 1 in the
case I symbol in the first sequence
equal to the J symbol in the second
sequence and as before we of course
preserve the backtracking problem with
backtracking pointers for the longest
common subsequence and in this case red
edge has great one as all other edges
have weight 0 and here are the
backtracking pointers for our particular
problem finding longest common
subsequence for these two strings and we
can move from the final destination
backwards using backtracking problem
backtracking pointers and suits
slowly but surely we will arrive to the
original node initial node and all
passes that are traced by the blue edges
represent the solutions to the longest
common subsequence problem to compute
backtracking pointers we have three
choices we can either record a
backtracking pointer as a vertical
horizontal or diagonal edge and as soon
as the backtracking pointers are
computed we can write a simple program
that allows us to output the longest
common subsequence by once again
exploring three choices
in choice blue choice and red choice we
have now learned that to compute a
scorer at a given known we need to
consider all edges entering into this
node and the initial the Arctic's of
each such edge is called a predecessor
of a given node and therefore the
recurrence e for computing the longest
passes in an arbitrary graph will be the
following one let's denote s of a as the
length of the longest path to node a and
to compute s of a we need to compute
maximum among all predecessors of node a
and we take maximum amonth the value
scorer of each predecessor plus weight
of that from this predecessor to a given
node so let's try to apply this approach
to a simple graph shown here we start
from the initial node and of course the
length of the longest path to this node
is zero and we can compute two other
scores for two other nodes four and six
and now let's try to compute score for
the node shown by the question mark
there are two edges entering into this
node score off one of them for one
predecessor is known at zero but score
off another predecessor is unknown
therefore before we compute the score
for the node shown by the question mark
we need to compute one more score which
is this one but to compute this scorer
we need to compute score in the nozzle
Arctic's shown here but to compute score
of this vertex we need to compute score
for this one and to compute score for
this one we need to compute the scorer
that we have been trying to compute some
time ago so we came to a vicious circle
it looks like a catch-22 we need to
compute something that has not been
computed yet but to compute
we need to compute something else again
and again and again so and which tells
us that the order in which we explore
nodes of the graph is extremely
important by the time the node is
analyzed the scores of all its
predecessor should already have been
computed and if the graph has a directed
cycle like the graph we just looked at
there is simply no way to solve the
problem because a traveler may travel on
this directed cycle as long as humans do
and therefore the limit attention to
so-called directed acyclic graphs or
dogs which are graphs without directed
cycles in this slide at this slide
Batman is looking at a directed acyclic
graph and is trying to solve a difficult
dressing in the morning prompt and
topological ordering of a graph is
ordering of nodes of the dark own line
such that all edges in the graph go from
left to right there are different ways
for this Batman to get dressed in the
morning and two of them are shown here
and each of them represents a
topological ordering because by the time
Batman needs to put something corn all
necessary Sanks already have been put on
in this particular case and there is a
simple theorem that we are not proving
but you can try to prove it to yourself
that every duck has a topological
ordering and in fact for our Manhattan
grid there are many different ordering
topological orderings and two of them
are shown on this slide and after we
learned that topological ordering is
important we can design pseudocode for
the longest path problem and it works
like this the first topologically
ordered the graph and then the update
nodes in the order given by the stop
illogical ordering as described on this
slide what is the runtime of this
algorithm
that we will use heavily in the reminder
of this lecture well when we run dynamic
programming we look at every agency
graph just once to update the note that
this edge goes into and therefore the
runtime of the dynamic programming
calculate for finding longest passes is
proportional to the number of edges in
the graph in we are now ready to look at
different varieties of sequence
alignment problems in biology